so what's the main difference between
these people who
are abusing and raping i mean
wouldn't you just classify them as
pedophiles like a pedophile cult
what's the difference between a satanic
ritual abuser and a pedophile
okay the reason i'm i'm making the
distinction
uh is because a pedophile normally
would have a a very strong
addiction to
having sex with children it's it's like
an overriding sexual attraction
to children and
that is not necessarily the case with
all satanist ritual abuses there are
satanist ritual abusers
probably many of them who will sexually
abuse a child
but do not have that strong
deep attraction to sex with children but
the reason why they sexually abuse the
child
is because it's part of the satanic
practices
it's part of their um belief system
that they should do it uh it's
not entirely accurate to say this but
it's
part of their religious practice you
could say i say it's not entirely
accurate because i don't
regard satanism as as a real religion
but drawing an analogy with religious
practices
they see it as their religious practice
and
so they sexually abuse the child but
they don't have that
strong sexual attraction to children
which is usually life
long which pedophiles have so it's not
strictly speaking accurate to call them
pedophiles
but we also need to make a distinction
between
the pedophiles and their activities and
the satanist ritual abuses and their
activities because satanist ritual abuse
is in a different universe from
pedophile activities your average
pedophile
does not deliberately torture children
in addition to the sex abuse your
average pedophile will not force
children to sexually abuse
each other as satanists do your average
pedophile is not going to bury a child
in the ground
making the child fear for his or her
life
and then later remove the child from the
ground
your average pedophile is not going to
ritually sacrifice
babies or adults or toddlers as
satanists do
you see we need to have this clear
distinction that's why
when i speak about sra i call it sra
and i don't call satanist abusers
pedophiles although they may
also be pedophiles in some cases
because too many people mix up
pedophile so-called ordinary child sex
abuse with
sra they are two very different things
and
the satanists play on this the satanists
take advantage of this
confusion by disguising
their satanic abuse as
so-called ordinary child sex abuse
and when they succeed in doing that they
succeed in concealing
sra and the reality of sra so for
example
in tim tate's book children for the
devil he mentions
an actual uk case where a boy was
subjected to sra
and had revealed that to the police when
he was interviewed
the boy was in foster care but
unfortunately
the father who was accused by the boy
of abusing him and who was a satanist
abuser
was allowed to visit the boy from time
to time
and when he visited the boy he did not
encourage the boy to say
no abuse occurred the interesting thing
is
he encouraged the boy to just drop
all the mention of satanism
the satanist rituals that he experienced
while being abused
the father was far more concerned that
the sra
not be revealed than the abuse itself
so he did not say to the boy don't say i
wasn't sexually abused by you
just drop all the the um
drop drop all the satanic stuff
and that showed what his priority was
protect
the coven protect satanism by having
that drop
and then it gets presented as a child
sex abuse case
rather than as an sra case and this is
why i say to victims it's so important
if you did
actually suffer sra to tell the
authorities you did actually suffer sra
otherwise people will never learn that
sra exists
they will carry on with the myth that it
doesn't exist
which will make it so much harder to
protect children from sra
you see we've got to break that cycle of
ignorance somewhere
and it starts with uh as the saying goes
call of spade is fake call
sra how many sra victims have you spoken
to
i haven't kept count but over the years
we're probably talking
a few hundred a few hundred
did any of them provide any sort of
evidence of
some of the stuff you're talking about
like sacrificing children
or torturing children or torturing
people
they gave me very reliable uh
witness statements about what they saw
the only other way for them to
give strong evidence would be to have a
picture a film a photograph
but obviously they would not have been
in a position
to to have taken such a picture or film
they wouldn't have survived
they would have been killed for trying
to take a picture of that
the interesting thing is that the
satanists themselves film their
activities
but they are so far pretty effective
in keeping the film in a very well
hidden place
uh but if one is able to find a film of
their activities then it's all there on
film
uh they they like to film their sra
and they
probably use some of it as pornography
and
sell it to make money but
the reliable witness testimonies
i would consider as strong evidence of
sra because as you go for example to the
criminal courts and those
successfully prosecuted sra cases in the
uk
are an example of this that you will
have witnesses
talking about sra and what happened in
the sra
and if the prosecution is successful in
convicting
the defendants that means
that the standard of proof beyond
reasonable doubt
has been reached on the evidence of sra
in the case
because if the sra was disbelieved then
the whole case crumbles because
what the defendants are alleging
took place was sra and it wasn't hidden
or disguised
in the courts it was openly shared by
the witnesses the witnesses were deemed
to be reliable and truthful
and so the prosecution was successful
and the very high standard of beyond
reasonable doubt
was achieved that's why i say that sra
has been proven in the british courts on
more than one occasion
on at least 10 occasions to be
existing in the uk beyond reasonable
doubt
so you're saying there are a number of
people in the uk who have been
convicted of crimes
for satanic ritual abuse uh not strictly
speaking the crime of satanic ritual
abuse because unlike certain states in
the u.s
like idaho who have codified
a law on sra specifically
we don't have such a law on sra yet in
the uk because of the general
disbelief so what we have are the
existing laws
which would of course cover different
aspects of sra
such as raping a child
obviously that would be a crime in the
uk right in the existing law
uh harming
physically harming a child that will
also be under existing law
um as often satan is due
pimping out a child for sex
that is also under existing law we would
like to see at some point
a law brought in on sra like similar to
the ones
in states like idaho and the u.s
because that would not only be official
acknowledgement of sra
in the uk law which could also be used
as
leverage to get more resources and
training
for the uk police to investigate such
cases
but that will also be a way to bring in
much tougher mandatory sentences
for sra much tougher than the existing
penalties for child sex offenses in the
uk
but we we have had successful
prosecutions
uh and the sra evidence was not withheld
it was openly shared in court
it was believed it was if it wasn't
believed the defendants would not have
been convicted
so the standard of beyond reasonable
doubt was satisfying
so when the witnesses i'm sure like you
said there was multiple witnesses in
some of these cases right
and a lot of their stories corroborate
how could one person be convicted if
i mean it sounds like these rituals
go down with lots of people there so
wouldn't it be more of a conspiracy with
lots more
people being prosecuted not just one i
mean is it one person by themselves or
is there
a group of people attending these
rituals what do they look like
you you will get in many cases a group
of people
at the rituals and sometimes
they will be successful in prosecuting
more than one person who participated in
the rituals
sometimes because of perhaps lack of
evidence against certain individuals
not all the participants will get
prosecuted
it just depends on
the witnesses
whether they can identify
the individuals whether they have
reliable evidence of seeing those
individuals
committing the crimes and
this is part and parcel of
how successful they are to prosecute
i